Speaker 1: Let's talk to people in the
audience. The audience matters and we
take calls via The David Pakman Show Discord,
which you can find at David Pakman dot com slash
discord. We're going to start today with
David from St. Petersburg. Now, is that St.
Petersburg, Florida, or St. Petersburg, Russia?
Speaker 4: Hi, David. Yes, in St. Petersburg,
Florida, Lovatt. Thank you for allowing
me to call. I've been listening a show
for about two years and I enjoy hearing
your perspective on a lot of issues.
Speaker 1: That's great, David. And please
silence those discord notifications.
They're already going off.
Speaker 4: Oh, yes, sir. Yeah.
Yes. So my my question is I'm a pretty moderate, I
would say, however, I'm having a little bit of an
issue with what I'm seeing sort of out of the left
right now. And what I mean by that is I almost
see free markets being almost a swearword when
I'm having lots of discussions with my friends
and they're talking about how it's a failed system
and we have to move past that. And they often use
Nordic countries as an example. However, I. I
know Nordic countries to be very free markets
that mainly use free markets to generate revenue
in order to pay for their social programs, which
which is great and it works wonderful
for them. However, I always hear people
talking about a need to move past this
system, but I haven't seen any system that
works for everybody and creates a society that
they want to create that is equitable and have
people be happy and taken care of without a robust
free market in order to have taxes that are then
taken out of them to provide services for people.
Speaker 1: Well, this is just fundamentally a
question of what is one's political and economic
philosophy, you one thing is we've got to first
be accurate. When they say we got to move
past the free market and be like Norway,
Norway, Denmark, Sweden, these countries have
markets for the vast majority of goods and
services. But what they've done is they've said
there should be some areas where there is either
extremely disproportionate power for things that
are necessary in the market, like, you know,
health care, education, et cetera, where we're
going to take things out of the free market.
So the first thing is to say we've got to get
away from free markets and be like Norway. It
doesn't make any sense. Some of a lot of those
countries have very good business environments
with a lot of freedom. So we have to start
with the facts, first of all. Secondly.
I am thinking some of the people that you're
talking about might be actual socialists or even
communists, is that right? Because for the most
part, if you're just a social Democrat like I am,
you're not saying eliminate free markets. You're
just saying there are some areas that should
be removed from the market. But it's fine for
markets to direct resources on mobile phones.
You know, DVD players, whatever the case
may be, it's just that there's certain areas
where we need more government involvement.
Speaker 4: Yes, I I agree with what you're
saying. The main issue is I have as I don't they
don't categorize themselves as socialists or
communists or they just say there are liberal
Democrats and they look at policies. I believe
that they don't look at the sort of the funding
necessary for some of these policies as well.
You know, for example, when we look at the Nordic
countries, they have these ideas that the rich
and the wealthy can fund everything and. It's
just impossible with everything they say that is
available, you know, such as the health care
Speaker 1: well to it to a great degree,
the disproportionate amount of funding for those
things actually can easily come from the very,
very rich. But it's sounding like the people
you're talking to are sort of all over the
place and they may not really know what they're
talking about because a lot of these arguments
kind of conflict. And, you know, I wouldn't
judge these movements by the people you're
specifically talking to, maybe would be my advice,
Speaker 4: really try not to. I really try not to.
It just seems that maybe it's just spending
too much time online and just talking about,
you know, people that are more of the millennial
age. I mean, you're a very educated person. And
most people that are educated, such as yourself
and in the political spectrum, you know,
clearly have moved past that idea. However, I
just see a very large portion of the voting bloc
not necessarily being so well informed as you are,
because, you know, obviously I bring these points
up to you and you're just rightfully saying,
oh, well, that's silly. You know, that's not
actually how it works and that's not how it is.
Speaker 1: Yeah. I mean, listen, it sounds like
you're saying a lot of people are engaging
in politics and not having any idea what's
going on. And I would agree there's a lot of
that on the left and right. But that's more of
a systemic education issue, I would say.
Speaker 4: Yes, yes, I agree. I see what
you're saying. It's just it seems that
I've just seen them more and more from,
you know, 15 years ago, and I just get
worried when elections happen. Well,
I'm not saying this is really going to happen. I
know. But, you know, maybe 20 years from now, just
people voting for policies that could
end up being more aimed towards Venezuela
rather than ignored a country that has
a very happy, successful population.
Speaker 1: Yeah, we're very, very far
from that. There's nobody even proposing
Venezuela type policy right now in any serious
way. So why should I watch that? All right,
David St.Petersburg, thank you so much for the
call. I appreciate the commentary from you. L